our series changing the game profiles
extraordinary women who are making a
difference now and for future
generations this morning we are speaking
with the ceo who is tired of smelly boys
sounds like my mom including her own she
started her own company chantel powell
noticed her son's strong odor from an
early age but she couldn't find the
right deodorant for him she founded play
pits in 2018 after experimenting with
ingredients in her kitchen now you can
find her deodorants in select target
stores nationwide chantel powell good
morning how you doing good morning
thanks for joining us so
what made you start your own deodorant
and how did you even know how to make
deodorant yeah
well what made me started was my son
literally
one day after football practice he got
in my car one hot july day
and changed my world what did you do
what did it smell like it sounded like
it was funky it was like a nfl locker
room after the super bowl
it was and how old was he he was sick
six and the odor was that strong it was
bad so how did you know how to make your
own deal
so when i was a little girl my
grandmother used to pat baking soda
under my arms right because every black
grandmother got some baking soda in the
refrigerator yeah so she would pat that
under my arms before i would play so i
knew that would help to neutralize oh
you know that's one ingredient that was
fun the next thing i used was coconut
oil because i knew that would kill
bacteria and it was anti antiseptic
so then i also had corn starch because
that absorbs moisture and the final
ingredient was the orange essential oil
because i knew if i could convince
cameron that he could smell this good
all day he would wear it and so that's
what i did we mixed that up and you just
started trying different things in your
well that first that first batch was
just literally just for cameron he went
to camp
and loved it so much that he came home
was like okay mommy so i told all the
kids at camp about this you got to make
it for everyone but i was a working mom
i was like no this is between me and you
it was good right yeah and he was like
but mom you could make this for everyone
and that was my light bulb moment that's
when i knew other parents deserved to
have kids that you know were confident
and able to play and kids deserve to be
able to play unapologetically now what
year was this this was 2017. okay 20 so
now we sit here in 2022 and you are in
target stores you're in target stores go
you number one
and target stores you said was a dream
for you why oh yeah target was always
the dream because i feel like that's
where all the cool moms are right like
you know the hangout spot escape those
kids run to target look at those hours
for what's hot what's new and what's
next and so
i always saw play pits as being what's
new and what's next because it was a
category that no one was really
attacking in the way that i knew i could
but lots of folks out there have ideas
but then it feels daunting or impossible
to go from that idea to store so what
was the first step to doing it making it
happen
making the formula yes so i think the
first step was branding it i wanted to
feel
like it was four kids all the actu the
natural starting with the name yeah it
started with the name play pits and i
joke because the logo came to me in
church i promise i was paying attention
in church
but it just dropped in my spirit and i
started sketching it out and so my kids
helped out with the branding the colors
the na each scent is named after one of
my three kids so you know it was really
developing the brand and making it feel
kid like it's not a deodorant that i
just slapped kids on yeah it's literally
inspired and crafted for children and
with kids in mind i could have used this
so back to your channel oh yeah yeah
yeah
so you got the name and then how do you
go from really getting it into the
stores i know you can't take us through
every step yeah so it didn't start it
really started off with me just making
this product and offering it to people
that i knew needed a deodorant for the
kids right so we did pop-ups locally in
the dc area so i'm from dc so uh dc
maryland you know we would do pop-ups
and i would find anything that i could
afford to go to and sell and that's how
i was able to connect with my customers
and so i tell people my customers are
not just customers they're called the
under army
they are forced to be reckoned with and
is it just for little boys and i ask
that now because so because the the
producer who produced this segment
alicia brown if i could say her name
yeah delicious shout out to alyssa
because in the meeting yesterday she
goes i can say that i use it and i can
tell you when i use it i don't smell i
didn't know alish had that problem
because i've never noticed that but she
said i don't smell and i just think
that's such a good tag line so it's not
just for little boys no because there's
there's a legend
wait nate there's a show lish again
so is it for girls boys adults yes so
it's for everyone so playbiz is inspired
by kids boys and girls right but it's
perfect for the entire family so i tell
people it's never been tested on animals
but it's been tested on all of my family
and friends yeah and so everyone uh
young boys smell like animals yeah
i wish i smelled like an animal i say i
could have used this when i was a kid
because i got to middle school and then
a girl said i smelled like hot dogs and
oh that's not good yeah that's not good
i needed play pits but you know what
what was wrong with the stuff that was
already out there cause i'm sure my mom
was looking for something yeah so for me
i wasn't interested in using an
anti-press mirror for cameron i wanted
something that was natural because the
anti-press mirrors are known to have
aluminum salt it's been linked to all
types of things and whether it's
confirmed or not i was not interested in
risking my child's health potentially in
the future for a small thing that i
could do now and that's not a healthy
decision how does cameron feel because
cameron's here yeah the whole family
knowing that that it started because
with the smell from and they smell good
listen i think he's proud i think he's
very proud we're all very proud of you
and i hear alicia keys is a customer oh
yeah i heard from reliability he has two
boys
that's a good individual well then this
girl is on fire
okay
congratulations
we'll be right back